presentiamo due persone in cina è molto
simpatiche cosa potrete soltanto
guardare lo spettacolo perché ci hanno
portato qui spettacolo ha detto sasha se
non sbaglio quello che non mangiava la
minestra era famiglia e quindi restano
due dovete pagare questa credenza bruno
è un'amica affidabile bruno passerai
presentiamo io la sindone piacere ciao
se salvatore le file un appello da qui
diamoci lo spettacolo vede soltanto
guardare
ok
[Musica]
e bravo ma sapevo che stava oltre 60
nota già preso un palloncino bello bello
scusate ma come so come ha fatto a farlo
spiega melo ma era proprio meglio cioè
bravo bravo nicoloso adesso arriva il
fiorellino ok io non voglio neanche
pensare dobbiamo fare il mood di cosa
potrebbe succedere non può dirlo in giro
lo stomaco tosta non è san valentino per
oggi per questo hai fatto colpo su ray
sempre se ne esce vivo nel senso era
così perché non sono ora ragazzi
attenzione
no no no no no no no no ragazzi lo sta
facendo di spalle veramente io non
guardo
tu fai le cose al contrario di solito
quando appena portati giri così infimi
le camere indietro uscire adesso tocca a
voi
la prima considerazione ma rete da parte
di bella
secondo che devo ritornare la palazza
digestato merito quindi ci vediamo dopo
da ciao ciao
vediamo se la centrale non si sa mai una
carta piccolina dopo l'altro è uscita la
cosa dirgli sbaglia così diventata un po
la cosa per cui viene ancora una cosa
ciascuno
stiamo regalando la distanza perché si è
spostato poi quando a tratti non però di
mangiare più preparate da ragazzi prima
lega supera maniera non è più in avanti
mira quello da noi piacciamo territorio
siano ma insieme insieme ma doveva
scherzo
e l'abbiamo avuto prende come un tronco
ok allora erano solo fine di mettere a
questa parte ben giro dopo giro vedo
parigi e che sta tremando anch'io alza
incredibile
no no io ho visto che brodo è bravo ha
trovato solo una volta su quanti 56 kg
che ha fatto però il problema sussiste
ero voglio morire giovane come te ha
detto lui maglioncini ragazzo era il
palloncino l'altro palloncino tra 24
negozio più o meno come la loro mente mi
fanno tutti raggiunto tutto questo ok
tanto che lancino sentito in bocca da
questa parte è piccolissimo forense su
restano tre mandati alla prossima volta
vedi quanto a tre domande che elena
timori sono professionisti del santo
padre
abbott quest'ambiente perché
si preoccupi guardi esiguo
a questo punto non so più cosa
aspettarmi perché ho davvero paura che
lo faccia ma lo possiamo fare girato di
spalle con lo spirito
fermi così cosa non ha mai espresso
sicuro sisti [ __ ]
un uomo di potere
non posso sbagliare due vogliono ragazzi
fermi tre giorni
ci siamo
sono pronti
ecco
ma abbiamo perso 107 milioni iscritti
sento un casino è stato orribile
insomma l'amore camera noi non poteva
dire niente non potevo fare niente rosa
che si canta messa